everyone welcome to this next episode of
your daily equation and today the the
focus will be on the concept of
curvature curvature why curvature well
as we saw in an earlier episode of your
daily equation and perhaps you know on
your own even if you didn't see any
previous episodes when Einstein
formulated his new description of
gravity the general theory of relativity
he made profound use of the notion that
space and time can be curved and through
that curvature objects are coached
nudged to travel along particular
trajectories that in the older language
we would describe as the gravitational
pull the force of attraction of another
body on the object that we are
investigating in Einstein's description
it's actually the curvature of space
that is guiding the object in its motion
so again just to put us on the same page
in a visual that I've used before but I
think it's certainly a good one here we
have space three dimensions hard to
picture so I'm gonna go to a
two-dimensional version that captures
all of the idea see that space is nice
and flat when there's nothing there but
and I bring in the Sun the fabric of
space curves and and similarly if you
look in the vicinity of the earth here
of two curves its environment and the
moon as you see it's kept in orbit
because it's rolling along a valley in
the curved environment that the earth
creates so the moon is being pushed
around into orbit by kind of grooves in
the curved environment that the earth in
this particular case creates and the
earth is kept in orbit for the same
reason it stays in orbit around the Sun
because the Sun curves the environment
and the earth is nudged into orbit by
that particular shape so with that new
way of thinking about gravity where
space and time are intimate participants
in the physical phenomena they're not
just an inert backdrop it's not just
that things are moving through a
container we see an Einstein's vision
that the curvature of space and time
time curvature is a tricky concept we'll
come to it at some point but just think
in terms of space it's easier so the
curvature of the environment is what
exerts this influence that causes
objects to move in the trajectories that
they do but of course to make this
precise not just animation in pictures
if you want to make this precise you
need the mathematical means for talking
about curvature with precision and in
Einstein's day he was able to thankfully
draw upon earlier work that had been
done by people like like Gauss and
Lobachevsky and riemann in particular
Einstein was able to grab these
mathematical developments from the
1800's reshape them in a manner that
allow them to be relevant for the
curvature of space-time for how gravity
is manifested through the curvature of
space-time but thankfully Reinstein he
didn't have to develop all that
mathematics from scratch and so what
we're going to do today is talk a little
bit about the tethered here by a wire
unfortunately because I am 13% yeah you
may say why am I always so low in power
I don't know but I'm gonna I'm gonna
take this out for a bit and see what
happens if it gets too low I'll plug it
back in anyway so we're talking about
then curvature and I think I'm going to
cover this in two steps maybe I'll do
both steps today but time is short so I
don't know if I will get to it I'd like
to talk first about just the intuitive
idea and then I would like to give you
the actual mathematical
formalism for those who are interested
but you know having the intuitive idea
in mind is is pretty vital pretty
important so what's what's the idea well
to get to the intuitive idea I'm going
to start with something that at first
sight won't seem to have much to do with
curvature at all I'm going to make use
of what I would like to call and what
people typically do call a notion of
parallel transport or parallel
translation what does that mean well I
can show you what it means with the
picture so if you have a vector say in
the XY plane some arbitrary vector is
sitting there at the origin if I asked
you to move that vector to some other
location on the plane and I said just be
certain to keep it parallel to itself
you know exactly how to do that right
you grab hold of the vector and in
notability there's a very nice way of
doing it I can copy it over here I think
paste good and now look what I can do
well that's beautiful
so I can I can move it all around the
plane this is fun and I can bring it
right to the specified location and
there it is I've parallel transported
the initial vector from the initial
point to the final point now here's the
interesting thing
that is obvious on the plane but will be
less obvious in other shapes if I were
to paste this again good there's the
vector again let's say I take a
completely different trajectory I move
it like this like this like this and I
get to the same spot I'll put it right
next to it if I could yeah you'll note
that the vector that I get at the green
dot is completely independent of the
path that I took I just showed that to
you right now I parallel transport
along two different trajectories and yet
when I got to the Green Point the
resulting vector was identical but that
quality the path independence of
parallel translation of vectors in
general does not hold in fact on a
curved surface it generally does not
hold and let me give you an example and
I've taken my son's basketball too uh he
hasn't doesn't know this I hope it's
okay with him and I should have a hand
and I have a pen around oh it's too bad
I was gonna draw up on the basketball I
could have sworn I had a pen around here
oh I do have a pen aha it's over here
all right so here's what I'm gonna do
them and play the same game but in this
particular case what I'm gonna do is in
fact let me do this on the plane too so
let me bring this back up here let me
just do one more example this here's a
journey that I'm going to take I'm going
to take a vector and I'm going to
parallel translate it on a loop here I
go I'm doing it right here on the plane
on a loop and I'm bring it back and just
as we found with the green dot P if I go
on a loop back to the original location
again the new vector points in the same
direction as the original let's
undertake that kind of a journey on the
sphere how I'm going to do that well I'm
going to begin with a vector over here
can you see that yeah I got to go higher
up this point over here and oh man that
really does not does not right at all I
think you have some liquid here maybe
there's contact lens fluid let's see if
I can get it to work
yeah sort of anyway you'll remember will
you remember how am I gonna do this
well if I had a piece of tape or
something I could use that oh gosh I
don't know anyway so here we go we're
all we're all good so anyway can you see
that at all that's the direction in
which I know what I'll do I'll take this
guy over here I'll use my my Apple
pencil there's my vector okay it's
pointing it's at this spot right here
pointing in that direction okay so you
will recall that it is pointing you know
right toward the window now what I'm
going to do is
I'm going to take this vector I'm going
to move it along a journey the journey
here's the journey let me just show that
you're now I'm going to go along this
black line here till I get to this
equator and then going to move along the
equator till I get to this point over
here and then I come back up so a nice
big loop that I do the high enough start
here down to the equator over to this
black line over here and then up here
alright now let's do that here's my guy
initially pointing like this so there it
is my finger and the vector are parallel
they're at the same spot all right here
we go so I take this I move it down
I'm parallel transporting it down to
this location over here I then move to
the other spot over here
what is harder to do and then up I come
here and now for this to really impact I
need to show you that initial vector so
hang on one second I'm just gonna see if
I can get myself some tape I do here we
go
beautiful alright guys I'm coming back
hang on already perfect alright oh sorry
about that what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna take a piece of tape alright yeah
it's good nothing like a little bit of
tape alright so here is my initial
vector it is pointing in that direction
over here okay so now let's play this
game again alright so I take this one
over here I start like that and now
parallel translating along this black
parallel to itself I get to the equator
okay I'm now gonna parallel transport
along the equator till they get to this
location and now I'm going to power
transport along that black and notice
it's not whoops
can you see it it's pointing in that
direction as opposed to this direction
I'm now right angles in fact I'm gonna
do this one more time it's just to make
this even sharper make a thinner piece
of tape aha
look at that alright we're cooking with
gas here alright so here's my initial
vector
now it really has a direction associate
with it it's right in there can you see
it that's my initial one maybe I'll take
this right up close here we go all right
we peril a transport vector is parallel
to itself parallel parallel parallel let
me get down here to the equator I'm
gonna keep going too low then I go along
the equator until I get to this one over
here that black line now I'm going to up
the black line parallel to itself and
look I'm now pointing in a different
direction from the initial vector the
initial vector is this way
and my new vector is that way
so or I should put it at this location
so my new vector is this way and my old
vector is that way so that was a
long-winded way of showing that on a
sphere a curved surface when you
parallel transport a vector it doesn't
come back pointing in the same direction
so what that means is we have a
diagnostic tool if you will so we have a
tool a diagnostic a diag that's kim han
diag oh my god let's see if we get
through this diagnostic tool for
curvature which is this path dependence
of parallel parallel transport
so on a flat surface like the plane when
you move from location to location it
doesn't matter the path you take when
you're moving a vector as we showed on
the plane using the iPad and notability
from here and here all the vectors are
pointing in the same direction
regardless of the path that you took to
move the old vector say to the new
vector right the old vector moved along
this path to the new vector you can see
they're right on top of each other
pointing in the same direction but on
the sphere we played the same game and
they do not point in the same direction
so that is the intuitive way that we are
going to quantify curvature we're going
to quantify it in essence by moving
vectors along various trajectories and
comparing the old and the new and the
degree of difference between the
parallel transported vector and the
original the degree of difference will
capture the degree of curvature the
amount of curvature is the amount of the
difference between those vectors all
right now if you want to make this so
look that's that's really the intuitive
idea right here and now let me just I'm
going to record what the equation looks
like and yeah I think I'm running out of
time for today for in a subsequent
episode I will take you through the
mathematical manipulations that will
yield this equation but let me just set
up the the essence of it right here so
first off you have to bear in mind that
you have to on a curved surface define
what you mean by parallel you see on the
plane the plane is kind of misleading
because these vectors when they're
moving around on the surface there isn't
any intrinsic curvature to the space so
it's very easy to
compare the direction of a vector say at
this spot with the direction of a vector
of that spot but you know if you do this
on the sphere right just dive back over
here vector is saying at this spot over
here really live in the tangent plane
that's tangent to the surface at that
location so roughly speaking those
vectors lie in a plane of my hand but
saying some arbitrary other location
over here those vectors lie in a plane
that's tangent to the sphere at that
location now I'm going to drop the ball
and notice that these two planes they're
oblique to each other how do you compare
vectors that live in this tangent plane
with vectors that live in that tangent
plane if the tangent planes are not
themselves parallel to each other but
are oblique to one another and that's
the additional complication that a
general surface not a special unlikely
plane but the general surface you have
to deal with that complication how do
you define parallel when the vectors
themselves live in planes that
themselves are oblique to one another
and there is a mathematical gadget that
mathematicians have developed introduced
in order to define a notion of parallel
it's called what's known as a connection
and the word the name is evocative
because in essence what a connection is
meant to do is to connect these tangent
planes in the two-dimensional case
higher dimensions in the higher cases
but you want to connect these planes to
one another in order that you have a
notion of when two vectors in those two
different planes are parallel to one
another
and the form of this connection it turns
out is something called gamma
it's an object which has three indices
so a to index object like something of
the form a say alpha beta this is
basically a matrix where you can think
about the Alpha and the beta as rows and
columns but you can have generalized
matrices where you have more than two
indices it gets harder to write them as
an array you know three indices in
principle you could write it as an array
we now have you know we've got your
columns you've got your rows and I don't
know what you call the third direction
you know the depth of the object if you
will but you could even generally have
an object that has many indices and it
gets very hard to picture these as array
so don't even really bother just think
of it as a collection of numbers so for
the general case of the connection it's
an object that has three indices so it
is a three dimensional array if you want
so you can call it gamma alpha beta nu
let's say and each of these numbers
alpha beta and nu they run from 1 up to
n where n is the dimension of the space
so for the plane or the sphere and would
be equal to 2 but in general you can
have an N dimensional geometrical object
and the way gamma works is it is a rule
that says if you start with say a given
vector let's call that vector components
e alpha if you want to move a alpha from
one location let's draw a little picture
say over here so let's say you are at
this point over here and you want to
move to this nearby point called P prime
over here but this might have
coordinates X and this might have
coordinates X plus Delta X you know
infinitesimal motion but gamma tells you
how to move the vector that you start
with say over here how you move that
vector
it's kind of strange picture how you
move it from P to P prime here as a rule
so let me just write it over here so you
take e alpha that component and you add
in in general a mixture given by this
guy called gamma of gamma alpha beta nu
Delta X beta times e nu sum over beta
and nu both going from 1 to N and so
this little formula that have just
recorded for you tells you it's the rule
for how to go from your original vector
at the original point to the components
of the new vector at the new location
over here and it's these numbers that
tell you how to mix in the amount of the
displacement with the other basis
vectors the other directions in which
the vector can point so this is the rule
on the plane these gamma numbers what
are they they're all zeros because when
you have a vector on the plane you don't
change its components as you go from
location to location if I had a vector
that would say whatever this looks like
you know 2/3 or 3/2 then we're not going
to change the components as we move it
around that's the definition of parallel
on the plane but in general on a curved
surface these numbers gamma are nonzero
and they indeed depend upon where you
are on the surface so that's our notion
of how you parallel translate from
location to location and now it's just a
calculation to use our diagnostic tool
what we want to do is now that we know
how to move vectors around on some
general surface where we have these
numbers gamma that say either you have
chosen or as we'll see in a subsequent
episode are naturally supplied by other
structures that you've defined on the
space such as distance relations this
okay
metric but in general now what we want
to do is use that rule to take a vector
over here and let's parallel transport
it along two trajectories along this
trajectory to get to this location where
say maybe it points like this and along
an alternate trajectory this one over
here this trajectory number two where
perhaps when we get there at points like
that and then the difference between the
green and the purple vector will be our
measure of the curvature of the space
and I can now record for you in terms of
gamma what the difference between those
two vectors would be if you were to
carry out this calculation and this is
the one that I will do at some point
maybe next episode I don't know call
that path one and call this path to just
take the difference of the two vectors
that you get from that parallel motion
and the difference between them can be
quantified how can it be quantified it
can be quantified in terms of something
called the Riemann I always forget if
it's two ends or two M's you know I
should know this I've been writing this
down for like 30 years I'm gonna go with
my intuition I think it's two ends in
one end but anyway so the Riemann
curvature tensor I am a very poor
speller Riemann curvature tensor
captures the difference between those
two vectors and I can just write down
what this fella is so usually we express
it si R with now four indices on all
going from 1 to N so I'll write this as
R Rho Sigma mu nu and it's given in
terms of this gamma this connection or
did I call it it can also often is
called the Christoffel connection
Chris I'll probably spill this run
Christofle connection whoops connection
some people change that name to the
Christ awful connection because as you
see the math gets pretty hairy after a
little while but anyway so what is this
you know actually I should say they're
different conventions for how people
write this stuff down but I'm going to
write it in the manner that is I think
you know a standard as any so D mu of
Gamma Rho times nu Sigma - a second
version of the derivative where I'm just
going to interchange some of the indices
so I've got gamma nu times Gamma Rho
times mu sigma okay because remember I
said that the connection the value of
those numbers can vary as you move from
place to place along the surface and
those derivatives capture those
differences and then I'm going to write
down two additional terms which are
products of the gammas Gamma Rho mu
lambda times gamma lambda nu nu that's a
new not a gamma gamma nu yeah that looks
better nu Sigma - now I just write down
the same thing with some of the indices
flipped around Gamma Rho times nu Lambda
gamma final term lambda mu sigma I think
that's right taupe that's right good
yeah I think we're just about done so
there is the Riemann curvature tensor
again all of these indices Rho Sigma mu
nu they all run from 1 to N for an N
dimensional space so on the sphere that
go from 1 to 2 and there you see that
the rule for how you transport in a
parallel manner from one location to
another
that's totally given in terms of the
gamma that defines the rule and
difference between the green and the
purple therefore is some function of
that rule and here precisely is that
function and this particular combination
of the derivatives of the connection and
the products of the connection is a
means of capturing the difference in the
orientations of those vectors at the
final slot again all repeated indices we
are summing over them I just want to
make sure that I did stress that early
on whoa come on stay back here did I
note that early on maybe I didn't
oh I haven't said that yet okay so let
me just clarify one thing so I have a
summation symbol over here and I haven't
written the summation symbols in this
expression because it gets too messy so
I'm making use of what's known as the
Einstein summation convention and what
that means is any index that is repeated
is implicitly summed over so even in
this expression that we had over here I
have a new and a new and that means I
sum over it I have a beta and a beta
that means I sum over it which means I
could get rid of that summation sign and
just have it implicit and that indeed is
what I have in the expression here
because you will note that I've done
something actually I'm glad I'm looking
at this because this looks a little bit
funny to me mu yeah I have you see this
summation convention can actually help
you catch your own errors because I
noticed that I have a new over here and
I was thinking sideways and I wrote that
that should be a lambda good so this
lambda sums with this lambda fantastic
and then what I'm left with is a row mu
nu and a Sigma and exactly have a row mu
a nu and a Sigma so that all makes sense
how about in this one
as this one goods I have a lambda and
the lambda there some over I'm left with
a row a new mu and a Sigma good okay so
that equation is now corrected and you
just saw the the power of the Einstein
summation convention in action that
repeated indices are summed over so if
you have indices that are hanging out
without a partner then that would be an
indication that you've done something
wrong but there you have it so that's
the Riemann curvature tensor what I've
left out of course is the derivation
where I'm gonna at some point just use
this rule to calculate the difference
between the vectors parallel transported
along different paths and the claim is
that this indeed will be the answer I
get that's a bit of an involved that's
not that involved it'll but it's a you
know take 15 minutes to do so I'm not
going to extend this episode right now
especially because unfortunately
something else I have to do but I will
pick that calculation up for the
die-hard Equation enthusiast sometime in
the not-too-distant future but there you
have the key so-called tensor of
curvature the Riemann curvature tensor
which is the basis for each of the terms
on the left hand side of the Einstein
equations as we will see going forward
all right so that's it for today that is
your daily equation the Riemann
curvature tensor until next time take
care